[Music]
whenever you feel sad or mad or nervous
or out of control write down what you're
thinking and then ask yourself is it
true how do I feel when I have this
thought how do I act when I have this
thought and what's the
outcome of the thought how would I
feel if I didn't have the thought what's
the outcome of not having that thought
then my favorite part of it is take the
original thought and then just ask
yourself whether or not that's
true and by directing my thoughts by
managing rather than being a victim so
many of my patients are victims of their
thoughts until they do the work this is
one of the things where do what the FI
say write down a 100 of your worst
thoughts take them through that process
and by the time you get to 30 they'll
stop bothering